all right hey everybody we're gonna jump
right in because putin's already
speaking and then we'll get caught up on
other stuff okay
the currents but we don't know the
details
there are probably opponents and
proponents of
developing better relations with russia
who will prevail
it's difficult to say hopefully
steps will be taken after this
summit well hopefully one might think so
uh but it would only mean a missed
opportunity if it happens
and the final question to a journalist
from canada
oh boy
hmm this is weird
is he saying russian please
this is weird
did you see the subtitles said three
tablespoons of water
that was weird
this is really weird we'll just try a
different
feed
[Music]
you said to a couple of my colleagues
you wanted unbiased
fair questions and coverage i have a
fair question for you it actually comes
from my nine-year-old daughter
who asked me before i left to come here
what is the big deal with the summit
and it's quite a complicated answer for
a nine-year-old so i'd like you
to explain to us in your own words
dear god why is this relationship
so complicated and also she'd like to
know and i'd like to know
why are young people not allowed to
protest
in russia nice throwing that in there
[Music]
that's great it's great that your
nine-year-old daughter is interested in
these questions
the answer is very
you need simple look around yourself you
need to see how beautiful the world is
[Music]
strength and adults i hope she doesn't
accidentally stab herself 20 times
i'm meeting
[Music]
those who live on our planet
and they're doing that they're
addressing issues that have to do with a
terrible weapon
which needs to be limited they need to
draw up
common rules refraining from using those
weapons they talked about
protecting
[Music]
providing food to everyone on the planet
no matter where they are
they'll talk about issues of health care
so that when children grow up they get
sick less often
they have the opportunity to study and
they have
the opportunity to look at the future
confidently and i hope
you share that at our meetings
i hope that you will cover our meeting
based on those considerations
i thank you for your attention all the
best
okay wow
wow
let's just give it a second biden's
coming up next
what a weird day
[Music]
all right so tutti poody is done he has
uh heading out and this live stream has
concluded
and we're standing by for joe biden
presumably
uh happening very very soon all right so
we're going to stand by
everything about it very very
uncomfortable if you're just joining us
the summit between joe biden and putin
went shorter than expected they were
thinking it could be four to five hours
and instead it went i think three hours
and 20 minutes or so
and so the press conference has started
early and we're here for it all right so
we're hoping to hear
from joe biden soon i have so many
things to go over with you this now will
be the site
of the biden press conference and that
will be starting
soon michael says via super chat doesn't
a vodka sound good right now david yeah
right i have it right here
um no it's water of course or water
as some people like to say i do want to
say thanks to kimi oyo
as well as jama kiro dad a monk
and a.g who have grabbed a twitch
subscriptions just in the early moments
of this live stream also big thank you
to joshua
scheck snyder who just signed up with
the nearly illegal coupon code
felony 21 on my website joinpakman.com
all happening today all right let's see
here
um i have now so um
i have now a bunch of different
things to go over um tucker carlson
had a clip yesterday
where i guess he said he thinks that the
feds might have had something to do with
the trump riots
this i have to see i have a whole folder
of material now
from um from
from tdpskate who's in the chat very
good yeah if anybody on twitch needs
help setting up their um
twitch prime subs tdps kate is in the
chat she also gave me a whole portfolio
of things to look at today
um let's take a let's take a listen to
what tucker had to say here this i have
to hear
but strangely some of the key people who
participated
on january 6th have not been charged
look at the documents the government
calls those people unindicted
co-conspirators what does that mean
well it means that in potentially every
single case they were fbi
operatives really in the capital on
january 6th
for example one of those unindicted
co-conspirators is someone government
documents identify only as person two
according to those documents person two
stayed in the same hotel room as a man
called thomas caldwell an
insurrectionist
a man alleged to be a member of the
group the oath keepers
person two also quote stormed the
barricades at the capitol on january 6
alongside thomas caldwell the
government's indictments further
indicate that kabul who by the way is a
65 year old man
yes dangerous insurrectionist was led to
believe there would be a
quick reaction force also participating
on january 6th
that quick reaction force paul was told
would be led by someone called person
three
who had a hotel room and an accomplice
with him hey guys
what the hell is tucker talking about
but wait here's the interesting thing
person two
and person three were organizers of the
riot
the government knows who they are but
the government has not
charged them why is that
you know why they were almost certainly
working for the fbi
fbi operatives were organizing
the attack on the capital right on
january 6th
if that's true they were organizing it
for trump right like he ignores
every article about alex jones says he
was talking to white house people
and there were police sympathetic to the
whole thing
and he ignores all of that and now just
says the oh the fbi planned the thing
according to government documents and
those two are not alone
in all revolver news reported there are
quote upwards of
20 unindicted co-conspirators in the
oath keeper indictments
all playing various roles in the
conspiracy who have not been charged for
virtually the exact same
activities and in some cases much much
more severe activities
as those named alongside them in the
indictments
huh this stuff is getting really old
really really old so it turns out that
this white supremacist
insurrection was again by the
government's
own admission in these documents
organized at least in part
by government agents man
he seems out of his mind guys there's a
particu
there's a moment hold on right here
where he looks
extra crazy ancients
are you shocked we're shocked we
shouldn't be shocked the royal
we he always uses is also really
annoying to us
because in march the fbi director
admitted that the bureau was
infiltrating as many dissident groups
that opposed the regime as opposed
so there it is guys uh tucker says that
um the fbi
it's not it wasn't trump's it was the
fbi i guess now that planned the uh
planned the riot um
let's see what else did i want to get to
today oh i do have some voicemails
i got a super chat that says just defund
the fbi
um oh oh oh hold on a second you know
what i did want to show you guys
uh let me see where this is
oh i might not actually have this ready
wait a second i just have to show you oh
no you know what i'm gonna get it from a
different place
so on on the last live stream
um i told you we were very close to a
new thumbnail format
for the um new channel
and we have it and it is just
unbelievable let me see if how can i get
this now
oh i see hold on give me one second on
this this is this is like
hold on file blocked what the heck
open a new window
check this out this do you guys remember
this clip
hold on a second
um this is just an absolutely perfect
thumbnail
i just absolutely love this so these are
going to start
why does it look so crazy these are
going to start showing up on the new
channel and you will know that it's the
live channel
because it's in yellow as opposed to
blue
and um it's going to be really good it's
going to be really good so that's all
happening
and you can sign up for the new youtube
channel it's all free
at davidpakman.compacmanlive and
exciting stuff so we've got new youtube
channel yes
exactly guys the vinnie dem
portfolio says via super chat hey david
level with me here man with all that's
going on is it worth staying in america
i want my kids to have a good life love
the show
that's a very personal decision you
would you are the only person who can
answer that
for yourself and your family i can't
tell you
um i want to say thank you to
6lj for the twitch sub as well as
junk saint and the wilhelm screen
new members 6 7 and eight today we do
have a very special coupon code today
uh in honor of vladimir putin you can
sign up with the coupon code
felony21 at joinpakman.com
vincent says david keep up the good work
greetings from amsterdam
did you see messi's goal i did not
a um an argentinian whatsapp group i'm
on people were going crazy yesterday but
i did not actually see
messi's goal a few other
super chats here um
yeah i mean this is this is dubious but
listen to this
so um i wanted to talk about um
relations of greece and turkey i know
we're not on that right now it's all
about russia
but um you know i was just thinking in
terms
of um you know
whether or not um you know the
turkey should be able to cross into
uh greek territories
um here's a troy york one we haven't
done these for a while
hey david this is woody underwood um
just wanted to wrap up joe biden
uh his performance at g7 was totally
humiliating
you know what's really funny i actually
tweeted about this earlier
um let me pull up my twitter uh what was
my exact tweet
uh where was it here
yeah the right seems completely
triggered by the
biden europe trip simply going
unremarkably and uneventfully fine it's
like nothing's even gone
particularly well biden has just been
doing the things a president would do
uh he hasn't been cucked it's just
uneventful you know it's gone fine it's
not even like we're saying it's amazing
oh it's amazing
it's gone fine he's just a president
he's doing the trip and people like troy
york are just so triggered by it the
united states has never had a
a so-called elected official president
such as him he's
totally humiliated us um
with his countless mistakes and gasps
and i think it's a total embarrassment
that we have a delusional deranged old
man like him in the white house
it's just not you know nobody nobody
cares you know it's all oh what's going
on here let's see
[Music]
and then now we're back out apparently
that was a glitch of some kind okay
let's see a couple other voicemails for
you guys
hi david hey david uh this is bill from
fayetteville uh
retired army officer oh whoa well hold
on actually i can't play that right now
uh oops there's a reason i can't play
that i got
another one from eric from massachusetts
about covid lies let's listen to that
yeah hey david it's better for mass
again i hate to be calling again like
this but you're a liar again
uh kaylee mcinerney never lied on the cd
she never lied he has since adjusted the
numbers
the numbers have been adjusted six
percent of the numbers is what the real
cases are
yep the real so for every million cases
that are reported only six percent of
those are true guys
and it is and they also said it's just
the common cause
that's what they said check this it's
the common cold my friends that's it
website but you don't want to do that do
you and also with the audits they're
figuring out yeah there were a lot of
illegal votes so it was the real life
a lotter illegal votes a lotter
illegal votes guys liar project much
eric from maps
um really really powerful message there
um it's actually escalating
significantly significantly um
let's see what else we've got here
like one of the only things i really
hate about america is like the
amount of fat people here um
because it's like what did she say the
amount of what
what what was that she hates the number
of what people
one of the only things i really hate
about america is like the
amount of fat people here i think she's
saying fat people
um because it's like you know since i
was sick
when i was growing up they still like
eat in front of me all the time
just like everything and i couldn't eat
hardly anything at all
and i'd like throw up a lot
oh my god this this can't be real
i can't even play what
and like i have to sleep and stuff like
that
and then when i got older and i had a
kid they told me
like that like they're like childhood
friends and stuff like that
they told me that i shouldn't be able to
have a sticker
on my car that says baby on board
because other people
um can't have babies oh my god all right
guys we're moving away from that
um i think that's it as far as
voicemails go um
i'm like sweating from that that was
wacky
i want to say thank you to amelia romero
amelia is commemorating today's
putin summit by grabbing a membership on
my website with the coupon code
felony21 welcome amelia you are new
member number
nine today also thanks to beef stews
vatarette david scotland
the hoosier daddy and windup cat
for the twitch prime subs very much
appreciate those as well
as we are just standing by for joe biden
here
um okay what else did i want to look at
today i had a few other things
oh i don't know if you guys heard jared
kushner
is get is publishing a a memoir
and i can't imagine a more boring book
to read
jared kushner has book deal publication
expected in 2022
sinister guy whoop no i don't want the
morning wire jared kushner son-in-law
former president trump
has a book deal broadside books the
conservative imprint of harper collins
announced kushner's book will be out in
early 22.
kushner has been working on it expected
to write about everything from the
middle east to criminal justice reform
okay
yeah he should explain why he didn't end
up solving that israeli-palestinian
conflict which he was going to
his book will be the definitive thorough
recounting of the administration and the
truth about what happened behind closed
doors
financial terms were not disclosed
kushner was often at the center of the
trump administration's policies
kushner labeled the white house response
to the pandemic a great success story
man what absolute and total trash trump
issued a statement last week that he was
writing like
crazy and had turned down two offers
from publishers
a claim widely disputed within the
industry yeah trump claims he
he was writing too apparently unable to
just
only allow it to be jared kushner who is
writing stuff trump's like i'm writing
too
i'm writing too and publishers are like
no you're not
no you're not by the way if you guys
want a good book
um
here's a book i just finished this last
night
it's pandemic fiction lawrence wright
who wrote going clear about scientology
this is a novel but it's based on a
pandemic
worse than covid19 it's from last year
it's really really good really really
good i highly recommend this book
just finished it last night the end of
october
by lawrence wright check it out
other super chats coming in i find it
amazing we can't get infrastructure
passed for ourselves while
china is spending billions on african
infrastructure yeah it's pathetic what's
going on here truly is
truly is and by the way speaking of uh
china
today i interviewed dr ashish ja
from brown university we talked about
lab leak
we didn't talk about woke but we did
talk about lab leak
and i think people will find it pretty
interesting let me see if it's even
possible
to give you a clip
hold on a second here
um no i guess it's not
it's not uploaded yet no it just
happened it just happened
but we talked about lab leak with dr
ashish
thanks to michael darris michael just
signed up at joinedpakman.com with the
coupon code felony21
and his new member number 15 today john
mckinney says if republicans win in 22
they will impeach biden harris and fauci
regardless it will cost dems in 2024.
bill clinton's 99 impeachment is the
reason gore lost in 2000
i don't know that i agree with that this
is the current gop we're talking about i
don't know if i agree with that john i'd
have to think about it a little more
ryan nowicki says a recent political
study from yale
shows a connection in identity politics
hurting progressive policy support
where neutral reporting garners more
support for the same policy what's your
view of it i tend to agree
intuitively i tend to agree
i want to say thank you to rap cities on
graz
for the 14 months subscribed via twitch
prime number 16 today
um
okay very good couple other things
i have the stream had to start
so quickly oh here's something we're
thinking of doing an nft
just for kicks like just as a funny
thing so we were thinking of
um offering an nft
either associated with our most viewed
video ever
on youtube was one idea or the first
mp3 of the show ever from whatever year
it was i don't even know i think it was
1982 was the first episode of the show
um
just for kicks you know what i mean so
there's a lot of different websites
where you can make the offering i don't
know my point is
if there's someone in the audience who
has really strong feelings about this or
could even help us figure out like
if we did it how would we want to do it
get in touch info at davidpakman.com
um but that's that's something we're
considering
very very strongly um i do have
more new channel intro submissions yeah
if people want to look at them
let's see if i can pull them up um
memes intros
can i add all of these to a
playlist let's see
add to windows media player yikes
okay so here's a bunch of different
possible clip
intros for the new youtube channel which
you can find at
davidpakman.compacmanlive
in fact let's see how it's doing
pacman live
here we go these are audience generated
elements
yep we've got our first 4 400
subscribers on pacman live
you can subscribe right now oh whoa
look at that another 20 just dropped in
appreciate that all right check it out
here are some possible
new intros here's the first one
it's going to be crazy that's another
one
another one
there's another one
here's another simple one
this one is just that's that's it i
guess
oh this one's glitching oh this one's
cool
and then it flips wow look at that
pacman live
all right that's i guess that's all we
have so far guys
um but i uh i oh i guess this
this might only upload every 10 now
that's interesting
all right very good we're standing by
for joe biden there
um jacob says sir have you heard of a
book called the power worshipers by
katherine stewart great in-depth
look into the threat of christian
nationalism i actually have heard of
that book yeah
i have i want to say thank you to
tweediculous larry nips
six string bandit msu pyromaniac
all of whom just grabbed subscriptions
via twitch
if you guys need help setting up your
twitch prime sub uh tdps kate is in the
twitch chat tdpskate please don't
don't harass her but she is able to help
you get things set up
and in honor of a very putin-centric day
we have a coupon code felony21
felony21 that works at joinpakman.com
um okay
bay photo says hello david sir if tucker
and folks like marjorie taylor green
think the fbi is complicit in 1-6 then
shouldn't they support the
bipartisan investigation of course they
should
of course they should but they don't
that would be it's sort of like
that the fact that these things conflict
um
shouldn't surprise us because the same
people tell us
everything was peaceful on january 6th
but it was really fake trumpists that
did the rioting
well hold on a second but if everything
was peaceful then what rioting was there
there wasn't writing right if it was all
peaceful it doesn't really make sense
um yeah not
doesn't come as a surprise unban
requests good question let me see if i
have any
i do
oh okay yeah a user who was pretending
to be producer pat
on twitch was banned because they
actually actually you guys want to hear
how sick people are and how desperate
for attention and depraved people are
last stream someone made an account
on they literally made the account on
monday
and then they messaged one of our
moderators green man and said hey
it's producer pat please mod me or
whatever green man
had like a sixth sense sixth sense
that this was not really producer pat
and talked to us on the discord and said
someone's claiming to be producer pat
and i said that's a good question maybe
it is producer pat and i asked pat
and pat said that's not me so they were
banned and then now they're appealing
the ban by saying why was i banned
you're banned because you were
pretending to be
one of our staffers and you were really
not
so um that's the explanation
that's the explanation big thank you to
edward
iwanski who just signed up at
joinpakman.com
edward doing an amer an amazing american
pro-american action of
signing up for uh membership by the way
today's voicemail i'll preview this for
you guys on today's podcast which has
already it's in the can as we say in the
business
um it's a guy it's a military veteran
who is anti-semitic
who says i'm anti-american take a look
at this
hi david hey david uh this is bill from
fayetteville a
retired army officer david i just want
to know why
you seem to be so anti-american so uh
when you see what biden has done uh well
his corrupt son the amount of money the
hunter uh
crime family has done james biden hunter
biden why you don't want to discuss
that the corruption of uncle joe uh
uh you know and ten percent goes to the
big man
tony babilinski and all that stuff and
you know you got you you
you like having your own country trash
by oman check out how smoothly he
transitions into anti-semitism
and tolede and the radical left are you
a solinski
aficionado there uh david as soon as he
said saul alinsky i assumed it was going
anti-semitic and then it does
you know uh i wonder david pakman it
sounds like to me
like you might be from jewish uh uh
forebears that
i'm from jewish forebears
uh three grizzly bears my grandparents
were three jewish grizzly bears
and then a lutheran uh brown bear
that was my uh those are my ancestors it
might have been uh
good god-fearing jews you see where uh
uh nadler has to remove the word god
from the oak to tell the truth
and witness uh and of course
uh uh uh yeah guys i'm very very nicely
done windup cat
i immediately had a sixth sense
that this guy was anti-semitic adam
schiff has got four pinocchios from the
washington post so
so nadler's jewish and adam schiff is
jewish a lot of focus on jews
and uh bernie sanders a socialist
marxist that
uh he's worth at least three million
dollars he doesn't give anything to
charity owns three houses
right you see you get the picture there
how about eric swalwell uh having
i don't think swalwell's jewish though
uh passionate sex uh violating his
marriage laws with his wife what
marriage laws
is this guy talking about and how do you
know the sex was passionate in that
affair
brittany and having met a very hot sex
with a
chinese communist spy name he sounds
actually jealous more than anything
christine thing you know david i think
you got a little problem hating your own
country you know
no the problem is i have people like
this guy who call me
um we actually ah i shouldn't even say
there there's i got a call yesterday
from let me just say i got a call
yesterday from authorities
and there someone is very very close
who made similar calls to this from from
winding up in a courtroom very soon
and hopefully i'll have something to say
about it soon it's it's this is serious
stuff we don't we don't mess around with
this stuff
we see there's all these highly educated
people like antifa and blm
a antifa see those uh three women one of
whom
stole 3.2 million dollars from the kitty
for the blm and uh and bought herself
four houses
you know uh that kind of stuff ain't too
good how do you like ant keeping blm
what they did
for a real estate renovation by eluding
and then burning uh
stores and businesses and jobs
destruction that wasn't a n t
foot that was d antifa in seattle and
portland and uh
in minneapolis and so on anyway you guys
get it really really sick guy
and and also anti-semitic to boot just
as a sort of
cherry on top as far as that's concerned
um
derethen says guilty of what jewishness
by association
so see this is this is where it gets
kind of annoying
i realize these crazy voicemails are
gold but you only seem to play crazy
ones
no no no no no i also play so-called
normal ones and the audience hates those
because people are bored out of their
minds
let me let me just play i don't want to
be insulting in any way but
just i'm going to pick random voicemails
okay
hey david this is doug in columbia
missouri i'm calling about the arizona
so-called audit which obviously we
should have outrage over
the the thing i don't think is getting
enough air is
the secretary of state in arizona has
said because of the
breaking of chain of custody of the
voting machines that were taken
to um she basically said that
um those voting machines are all gonna
have to be replaced and that's a cost of
uh multiple million dollars um
you know it's like okay all right i
gotcha here's another random one
hey david this is brian from arizona i
just watched your show
and um from today and i you mentioned
something about
you know authoritarians on the left and
i just wanted to
kind of say yeah you know i've been
noticing that too and
one thing that i thought you know maybe
you would cover is i was watching on
bill maher's show a couple of weeks ago
i think it was a monologue or something
he was like just comparing the us to
china and he was kind of saying oh you
know the u.s is supposed to look at all
these things china's done
and some of them were true about
infrastructure and stuff but one of the
things he mentioned was
a common propaganda point from the
chinese communist party which is like
that they listed so many people out of
poverty
which at best was them playing with
definitions
and just stuff like that it's like that
goes on for three minutes you know is
that if people want that i guess i'll do
it but
here's another one hey david i was just
watching some news reports in regards to
mass shootings and i had a question in
regards to the
topic of discussion notice uh when mass
shootings happen
uh we talk about how it's a quote
unquote mental health issue
but uh every country in the world has
mental health issues how does that stop
an entire country from moving forward
with uh
legislative progress if uh that's a good
point everybody actually has
mental health issues in every country
but the difference is we have
citizens that are horsemen right
this is a good question from miami beach
yacht club isn't every lunatic nowadays
required to be an anti-semite is it part
of the crazy starter set
yeah basically basically
[Music]
let's pick another random voicemail
here it is hey david i
am a huge fan of your show i think
everything you do is great
um i love how you break down all the
individual
points and arguments my question is
you know by talking about
people like marjorie taylor green and
donald trump
and these ideas are we giving too much
is that giving them more power than they
deserve
or is that a good thing to do or a bad
thing that's basically my question i
think you get the gist of it
yep we've we've addressed that before
it's a fair question one we've addressed
many
um the eggman weighed in on masks
again if i was taking public
transportation during cold and flu
season
i would wear two [ __ ] masks but
that's not what i was talking about
and i agree with all you guys cool
alone all right shalom to the eggman
uh so that's that i mean that's kind of
just a tour through
some recent um recent recent voicemails
um a couple people interested
in when i interviewed jordan peterson
let's
i'll look at a little bit of that i
haven't looked at this for a while
let's just see i i don't even today i
don't even remember what the interview
was like let's just jump into like the
middle
and just see what jordan peterson said
this way of
of postmodern ideas and the more radical
post-modernists and
you see them particularly in fields like
women's studies and all the ethnic
studies groups that have
uh disciplines that have been generated
since the late 70s
their goals are quite straightforward
they want to reconstruct the patriarchy
and so the patriarchy basically means
our civilization as it currently stands
which they regard as
it is hard to take this seriously now in
light of everything that happened since
but
you're repairably corrupt let me pause
there if i can only because
we're we we have limited time of course
because of because you do have to get to
a class and we're starting to drift a
little bit from from maybe what uh
was the main focus of it let me cut to
the chase as i see it and see what your
thought on this is um i think that
there's a very good
possibility here that you're presenting
the superior argument with regard to to
the c-16
bill in canada however i'm wondering
from a purely pragmatic perspective
whether you'd not have more support in
terms of your position
on c16 if you didn't
uh communicate what and i'll be very
upfront with you in terms of the way i
interpret it and i don't think i'm the
only one and i don't mean this as a
criticism but just as sort of as an
analysis of how i see it
significant level of hostility towards
transgender
individuals as a separate issue from
that of
of gender-neutral pronouns i'm wondering
and i'll give you a chance to respond of
course whether
if a student requests an accommodation
with regard to a pronoun
even if you don't think that this makes
any sense even if many people don't
think the program will begin in two
minutes
two minute warning makes any sense might
not making some effort to
to go forward with that accommodation
put you on much stronger footing then
for your opposition to c16
and and the sort of uh legislation
of this type of language i'm not
thinking out loud i don't know what you
think
well i don't know if it would put me on
stronger footing it would certainly be
easier i can tell you that
it isn't obvious to me that the
appropriate thing to do when
you're compelled to use words that you
don't
agree with that the right thing to do is
to go ahead and use them
so i regard the made-up pronouns the zhi
and jur and so forth as
part of the vanguard of this post-modern
movement sure but
in what way are you hurt by just doing
that if it makes a student more
comfortable if it makes them
take more away from the class because as
they see it not as you see it maybe not
as i see it but as they see it
they're being addressed in the way that
they want to be addressed
in what way is that jeopardizing you or
your teaching
this is where i thought maybe he was
going to cry or or the material in class
for example
well i don't think there's any evidence
that it will make things better for them
it's just a supposition in fact i think
that
the demand to be marked out with the
special use of pronouns which by the way
don't change very frequently in the
english language they're very fixed
words i think that
yeah it's all so boring now right like
thinking back to that it's like what a
waste of time all of that stuff was it's
weird
are old audios of the original radio
show archived somewhere
yes members on my website get access to
a full archive
and i would encourage you to check it
out i want to say thank you to crispy
vibes
as well as bean products
ky dizzle has gifted four subs that's a
total of six
putting us at 27 and we are if you're
just joining us we are honoring the fact
that today is a putin-related day
with a coupon code on my website
felony21
how many felonies has vladimir putin
been associated with
you can use it at joinpakman.com
coupon code felony
21 costel iliescu was apparently bored
by the normal voicemails and said please
go back to the crazy voicemails
thanks and love your show parkman
thank you very much appreciate that
uh vladimir putin has already spoken
and then we are now standing by for joe
biden this will be a press
conference questions will be taken
republicans are standing by
for joe biden to be unable to even put
together a sentence
so far those hoping for that have been
disappointed i think
but you may be interested to know that
tonight on hannity
or hannity as i call it donald trump
will be appearing to give his analysis
of this
now is it sad that a former president is
going on like the 9 or 10 p.m eastern
fox show to analyze this summit
president of the united states
is that sad or is it funny i don't know
but uh here comes joe biden oh with the
glasses full power move
and there off they go no mask been a
long day for y'all
i know it was easy getting into the uh
the pre-meeting there was no problem
getting through those doors was it
wasn't it anyway hello everyone
uh well
i've just finished the uh the last
meeting
of this week's long trip uh
the u.s russian summit i'm gonna refresh
because the audio is totally out of sync
one there's no substitute as those
you've covered it's still out of sync
let's just try one other stream it's
pretty straight forward to me
this one's better one there's no
substitute as
those of you have covered me for a while
know for face-to-face dialogue between
leaders
none and president putin and i
had a share unique responsibility
to manage the relationship between two
powerful and proud countries
a relationship that has to be stable
and predictable and it should be able to
we should be able to cooperate where
it's in our mutual interest
and where we have differences i want to
president putin understand
why i say what i say and why i do what i
do
and how we'll respond to specific kinds
of actions
that harm america's interest now
i told president putin my agenda is not
against russia
or anyone else it's for the american
people
fighting covenant 19 rebuilding our
economy
re-establishing relationships around the
world our allies and friends
and protecting the american people
that's my
responsibility as president i also told
him that no president of the united
states
could keep faith with the american
people if they did not speak out
to defend our democratic values to stand
up for the universal and fundamental
freedoms that all
men and women have in our view that's
just part of the dna of our country
so human rights is going to always be on
the table i told them
it's not about just going after russia
when they violate human rights
it's about who we are how could i be the
president of the united states of
america
and not speak out against the violation
of human rights i told him
that unlike other countries including
russia
we're uniquely a product of an idea
you've heard me say this before again
and again
but i'm going to keep saying it what's
that idea
we don't derive our rights from the
government
we possess them because we're born
period and we yield them to a government
and so the forum i pointed out to him
that
that's why we're going to raise our
concerns about cases like alexis navalny
i made it clear to president putin that
will continue to raise
issues of fundamental human rights wow
because that's
what we are that's who we are the idea
is we hold these true self-evident
but all men and women this definitely
sounds different than
putin said he didn't do anything and i
believe him work
of commitment and included more and more
people and i raised the case
of two wrongfully imprisoned american
citizens paul whalen and trevor reed
i also raised the ability of radio free
europa ready liberty to operate
and the importance of a free press in
freedom of speech
i made it clear that we will not
tolerate attempts to violate our
democratic sovereignty
or to stabilize our democratic elections
then we would respond
the bottom line is i told president
putin that we need to have some basic
rules of the road
that we can all abide by i also said
there are areas where
there's a mutual interest for us to
cooperate
for our people russian and american
people
but also for the benefit of the world
and the security of the world
one of those areas is strategic
stability
you asked me many times what was i going
to discuss with putin before i came i
told you i only negotiate with the
individual and now i can tell you
what i was intending to do all along
and that is to discuss and raise the
issue of strategic stability
and try to set up a mechanism where we
dealt with it
we discussed in detail the next steps
our countries to take
on arms control measures the steps we
need to take to reduce the risk of
unintended conflict
and i'm pleased that you agreed today to
launch a bilateral strategic
stability dialogue diplomatic speak for
saying
get our military experts and our our
diplomats together
to work in a mechanism that can lead to
control of
new and dangerous and sophisticated
weapons that are coming on the scene
now that reduced the times of response
that raised the prospects of accidental
war
and we went into some detail of what
those weapons systems were
another area we spent a great deal of
time on was cyber
and cyber security i talked about the
proposition that certain critical
infrastructure should be off
limits to attack period by cyber or any
other
means i gave them a list if i'm not
mistaken i don't have it in front of me
16 specific entities
16 defined as critical infrastructure
under us policy i don't know biden
putin said they didn't do the hacking
and i believe the guy why would he lie
to me
the principle is one thing it has to be
backed up by practice
responsible countries need to take
action against criminals
who conduct ransomware activities on
their territory
so we agreed to task experts
in both our both our countries to work
on specific
understandings about what's off limits
and to follow up on specific cases that
originate
in other countries in either our
countries
there's a long list of other things we
spent time on
from the urgent need to preserve and
reopen humanitarian carters in syria
so that we can get food just simple food
and basic necessities
the people who are starving to death how
to build it
and and how it is in the interest of
both rushing the united states
to ensure that iran iran does not
acquire nuclear weapons we agreed to
work together there because as much as
interest
russia's interest is ours and to how we
can ensure the arctic remains a
region of cooperation rather than
conflict i caught part of
president uh trump putin's
press conference and he talked about the
need for us to
be able to have some kind of modus
operandi where he dealt with
making sure the arctic was in fact a
free zone
and to how we can each contribute to the
shared effort of preventing the
resurgence of terrorism in afghanistan
it's very much in
in the interest of russia not to have a
resurgence of terrorism afghanistan
there are also areas that are more
challenging i communicated the united
states unwavering commitment to the
sovereignty
and territorial integrity of ukraine
we agreed to pursue diplomacy related to
the minx
agreement did you and i shared our
concern about belarus
he didn't disagree with what happened he
just has a different perspective what to
do about it
but i know you have a lot of questions
so let me
close with this
it was important to meet in person so
there can be no mistake about or
misrepresentations
about what i wanted to communicate i did
what i came to do
number one identify areas of practical
work
our two countries can do to advance our
mutual interest
and also benefit the world two
communicate directly directly that the
united states will respond to actions
that impair our vital interests
or those of our allies and three to
clearly lay out our country's priorities
and our values
so we heard it straight from me and i
must tell you
so the best moment so far is the trump
putin slip for sure
[Music]
was what was was good positive
there wasn't any any strident action
taken
well we disagreed i disagreed stayed at
where it was
he disagreed he stated but it was not
done
in a hyperbolic atmosphere that is too
much of what's been going on over this
last week
i believe i hope the united states has
shown the world
that we are back standing with our
allies
we rallied our fellow democracies to
make concert
commit concerted commitments to take on
the biggest challenges our world faces
and now we've established a clear basis
on how we intend to deal with russia
and the u.s russian relationship there's
much more work
ahead i'm not suggesting any of this is
done we've gotten a lot of business done
on this trip
and before i take your questions i want
to say one last thing
folks look this is about
this is about how we move from here
this is i listened to again a
significant portion of what president
putin's press conference was
and as he pointed out this is about
practical straightforward no-nonsense
decisions no malarkey to make or not
make
we'll find out within the next six
months to a year whether or not we
actually have a strategic dialogue that
matters
we'll find out whether we work to deal
with
everything from release of people
in in russian prisons or not
we'll find out whether we have a cyber
security arrangement that
begins to bring some order because look
the countries that most are likely to be
damaged
failure to do that are the major
countries
for example when i talked about the
pipeline
that cyber hit for 5 million that
ransomware hit in the united states they
hit him cyberly
i looked at him and said how would you
feel if ransomware took on the pipelines
from your oil fields
i said it would matter this is not about
just our self-interest
it's about a mutual self-interest i'll
take your questions and as usual folks
they gave me a list
of the people i'm going to call on so uh
jonathan associated press
here we go thank you sir
uh u.s intelligence has said that russia
tried to interfere in the last two
presidential elections
and that russia groups are behind hacks
like solar winds and some of the
ransomware attacks you just mentioned
putin in his news conference just now
let's see if we can get to one where we
see yeah here we go
the consequences you threatened him
whether i the audio's a little out of
sync
he knows i will take action i'll try one
more refresh to see if i can
win this last time out it's okay what
happened was
we in fact made it clear that we were
not going to continue to allow this to
go on
the end result was we ended up
withdrawing and they went
join ambassadors we closed down some of
their facilities in the united states
etc
he knows their consequences now look one
of the consequences
that i know i don't know i shouldn't i
shouldn't say this unfair me
i suspect you may all think doesn't
matter
but i'm confidence matters to him a
confident matter to him
and other world leaders of big nations
his credibility people want to try one
more we can try it see if we can get the
best of both worlds
interfering with the elections directly
of other countries
and everybody knew it it's synced let's
see if we see the reporters
if we engage in activities that he is
engaged in
it diminishes the standing of a country
that is desperately trying to make sure
it maintains its standing
as a major world power and so it's not
just what i do
it's what the actions that other
countries take in this case russia
that are contrary to international norms
it's the price they pay
they are not they are not able to
dictate what happens in the world
there are other nations of significant
consequence i.e the united states of
america being one of them
mr president just a quick follow on the
same theme of consequences you said just
now that you spoke to
him a lot about human rights what did
you say would happen if opposition later
i guess we're not going to see the
reporters i don't know
i made it clear to him that i believe
the
the consequences of that would be
devastating
for russia i'll go back to the same
point what do you think happens
when he's saying it's not about hurting
the bonnie does he
all the stuff he says to rationalize the
treatment of the violin
and then he dies in prison
i pointed out to him that it matters a
great deal
when a country in fact and they asked me
why i thought it was
important to to continue to have
problems with the president of syria
i said because it's a violation
international norm
it's called the chemical weapons treaty
can't be trusted
it's about trust it's about their
ability to influence other
nations in a positive way look
would you like to trade our economy for
russia's economy
would you like to trade and by the way
we talked about trade i don't have any
problem with doing business with russia
as long as they do it based upon
international norms it's in our interest
to see the russian people do well
economically i don't have a problem with
that but
if they do not act according to national
norms
then guess what that will not only won't
happen with us
it will not happen with other nations
and he kind of talked about that didn't
he today
about how the need to reach out other
countries to invest in russia
they won't as long as they
are convinced that in fact the
violations for example
the american businessman who was in
house arrest and
i pointed out you want to get american
business to invest
let them go change the dynamic
right because american businessmen
they're not we're ready to show up
they don't want to hang around in moscow
i mean i look guys
i know we make foreign policy out to be
this great great skill
that somehow is sort of like a secret
code
all foreign policies is a logical
extension of personal relationships
it's the way human nature functions and
understand
when you run a country that does not
abide by international norms and yet you
need those international norms
to be somehow managed so that you can
participate in the benefit the flow from
them
it hurts you that's not a satisfying
answer
biden said he'd invade russia you know
by the way that was a joke that's not
true they'll say it either way
it is it is is more complicated than
that
um david sanger
i thought i just saw david there he is
thank you mr president um in the run-up
to this
uh discussion there's been a lot of talk
about the two countries
spilling down into a into a cold war and
i'm wondering
if there was anything that you emerged
from in the discussion that made you
think that here would take my coat off
the sun is hot
anything that would make you think that
mr putin has
decided to move away from his
fundamental role as a disrupter
particularly a disruptor of nato and the
united states
and if i could also just follow up on
your description of how you gave him a
list
of critical infrastructure in the united
states did you lay out
very clearly what it was that the
penalty would be for interfering in that
critical infrastructure did you leave
that vague did he respond in any way to
it
let me answer your first i'll answer
your second question first
i pointed out to him we have significant
cyber capability and he knows it he
doesn't know exactly what it is but it's
significant
cyberly we are strong if in fact they
violate
these basic norms we will respond
cyber he knows in the cyber way
number two i uh i think that
the last thing he wants now is the cold
war
without quoting him which i don't think
is appropriate let me ask a rhetorical
question
you've got a multi-thousand-mile border
with china
china is moving ahead hell-bent on
election as they say
seeking to be the most powerful economy
in the world the largest and the most
powerful military in the world
you're in a situation where your economy
is struggling
you need to move it in a more uh
aggressive way than in terms of growing
it
and you uh
i don't think he's looking for a cold
war with the united states
i don't think it's about a as i said to
him i said your generation of mine are
about 10 years apart
this is not a kumbaya moment as he used
to say back in the 60s in the united
states like
let's hug and love each other but it's
clearly not in anybody's interest
your countries are mine for us to be in
a situation where we're
in a new cold war and i truly believe he
thinks that
he understands that but that does not
mean he's ready to quote figure legend
lay down his arms and say
come on he still i believe is concerned
about
being quote encircled he still is
concerned that
we in fact are looking to take him down
et cetera he still has those concerns
but i don't think they are the driving
force it's the kind of relationship he's
looking for with the united states
jennifer jennifer jacobs
[Music]
thank you mr president is there a
particular reason why the summit lasted
only about
three hours we know you had maybe a lot
of four to five hours was there any
reason it ran shorter
um also did president putin said that
there were no
threats or scare tactics issued do you
agree with that assessment that there
were no threats or scare
tactics and also did you touch on
afghanistan and the safe withdrawal of
troops
yes yes yes and yes let me go back to
the first part
uh the reason it didn't go longer
is when the last time two heads of state
have spent over two hours
in direct conversation across the table
going into
excruciating detail
you may know of time i don't i can't
think of one
[Music]
our defense our intelligence and our
form well our
my foreign minister was foreign minister
my secretary of state was with me the
whole time foreign minister our
ambassador etc
we brought everybody in we had covered
so much
and so there was a summary done by him
and by me of what we covered
labroff and lincoln talked about what we
had covered
we raised things that required more
amplification or
made sure we didn't have any
misunderstandings and uh
and so it was uh that it was kind of
after two hours there we looked at each
other like
okay what next
what is going to happen next bring out
the vodka be able to look back
look ahead in three to six months and
say
did the things we agreed to sit down and
try to work out did it work
do we are we closer to a major strategic
stability talks and and progress
are we further along in terms of and go
down the line that's going to be the
test i'm not sitting here
saying because the president and i
agreed that we would do these things
that all of a sudden it's going to work
i'm not saying that what i'm saying is i
think there's a genuine prospect
to significantly improve the relations
between our two countries
without us giving up a single solitary
thing based on principle
and their values no no no
no there were no threats there were as a
matter of fact uh
um i heard he quoted my mom and quoted
other people today
there was it was very as we say which
will shock you coming from me somewhat
colloquial
um and we talked about basic basic
fundamental things it was a
it was and you know how i am i explain
things based on personal basis
what happens if for example and so
there are no threats just there's simple
assertions
made and no well if you do that then
we'll do this
with anything i said just
letting him know where i stood what i
thought we could accomplish together
and what in fact if it was if there were
violations of american sovereignty what
we would do
[Music]
no he asked us about afghanistan he said
that
he hopes that we're able to maintain
some
peace and security and i said that has a
lot to do with
you he indicated that he was prepared to
quote
help on afghanistan i won't go into
detail now and help
on on on iran and help on
in return we told a lot what we wanted
to do relative to bringing some
stability
and economic security their physical
security to the people of
syria and libya so we had those
discussions
yamiche
[Music]
thanks so much mr president um did you
say that you didn't issue any threats
were there any ultimatums made when it
comes to ransomware
and how will you measure success
especially when it comes to these
working groups on
on russian meddling and on cyber
security well it's going to be real easy
they either for example on on cyber
security are we going to work out where
they take action against the ransomware
criminals on russian territory they
didn't do it
i don't think they planned it in this
case and
are they going to act we'll find out
will we commit
what can we commit to act in terms of
anything affecting
the violating international norms that
negligence affects
russia what are we going to agree to do
and so i i think we have
real opportunities to to move and i
think that
one of the things that i noticed when we
had the larger meet
is that people who are very very well
informed
started thinking you know
this could be a real problem what
happens that ransom fair outfit were
sitting in florida or maine and took
action as i said on their
their their single lifeline to their
economy
oil it'd be devastating and they're like
you could see them kind of go
now we'd do that but like whoa
so it's ever it's and everybody's
interested these things be acted on
we'll see though
what happens from these groups we put
together
[Music]
the third one yes go ahead um mr
president
when president putin was questioned
today about human rights he said the
reason why he's cracking down on
opposition leaders
um is because he doesn't want something
like january 6 to happen in russia and
he also said
he doesn't want to see groups formed
like black lives matter what's your
response to that please
[Music]
my response is kind of what i
communicated but i think that's a
that's a ridiculous comparison it's one
thing for
literally criminals to break through
gordon go into the capitol kill a police
officer
and be held unaccountable and it is for
people
objecting and marching on the capital
one saying
you are not allowing me to speak freely
you are not allowing me to do a b
c or d and so they're very different
criteria
um steve steve holland reuters
president sorry president putin said he
was satisfied with the answer
about your comment about him being a
killer
could you give us your side on this what
did you tell him
he's satisfied why would i bring it up
again
you talk to him do you believe you can
trust him
look this i'm finding this pretty
interesting
this is about self-interest and
verification self-interest
that's what it's about so i uh
virtually almost almost anyone
that i would work out an agreement with
that affected the american people's
interest
i don't say well i trust you no problem
let's see what happens
you know as that all expression goes the
proof of the pudding is in the eating
we're going to know shortly igor radio
free
europe and radio liberty hello mr
president
hello you want to go on the shade you
can't can you see thank you yeah
yeah yeah yeah uh so
uh i think you know attacks in civil
society
and the free free press continue inside
russia
yes for example radio free europe yes
radio liberty voice of america current
time tv channel where i work
uh brand that uh foreign agents
uh and several other independent media
so uh we are essentially uh being forced
out in russia 30 years after president
yeltsin
invited us in my question is after
your talks with president putin um
how interested do you think he's in
improving
the media climate in russia not very
i wouldn't put it that way right in
terms of improving the climate
i would in fact put in terms of
how much interest does he have in
burnishing russia's reputation
that is not as viewed as not being
contrary to democratic principles in
free speech
right that's a judgment i cannot make i
don't know
but it's not because i think he uh he's
interested in
changing the nature of a closed
society or closed government's actions
relative to
what he thinks is the right of
government to
all right i'm told this is the best
stream so we're making one more switch
approach and you know there's a couple
really good blog i told him i read a
couple i read most everything he's
written
and the speeches he's made and and i've
read a couple very good biographies
which many of you have as well
and i think i pointed out to him that
[Music]
russia had an opportunity of that brief
shining moment
after gorbachev and after things began
to
change drastically to actually generate
a democratic government
but what happened was it failed and
there was a great
great
[Music]
[Laughter]
race among russian intellectuals
to determine what form of government
would they choose
and how would they choose it you know
trump contextualized his helsinki
meeting with
the exact same knowledge of history do
you guys believe that
russia has always been a major
international power when it's been
totally united
as a russian state not based on ideology
whether it was going back to czar and
commissars straight through
to the the revolution the russian
revolution
uh and to where they are today
and i think that it's clear to me and
i've said it that i think he decided
that
the way for russia to be able to sustain
itself as a great
quote great power is to in fact
unite the russian people on just the
strength of the government the
government controls
not necessarily ideologically but the
government and
i think that's the that's the choice
that was made
i think it i i'm not going to second
guess
whether it could have been fundamentally
different
but i do think it does not lend itself
to
russia maintaining oh he's wrapping
powers in the world
[Music]
grabbing his jacket
did military response ever come up in
this conversation today
did you in terms of the red lines that
you laid down
is military response an option for a
ransomware attack
and president putin had called you in
his press conference an experienced
person
you famously told him he didn't have a
soul do you now have a deeper
understanding of him after this meeting
right
thank you very much
[Music]
dialogue and also with what you said at
nato that the biggest problems right now
are russia and china you've spoken many
times about how you've spent
perhaps more time with president xi than
any other
world leader so is there going to become
a time where you might call him
old friend to old friend and ask him to
open up china
to the world health organization
investigators who are trying to get to
the bottom of coba 19. let's get
something straight we know each other
well we're not old friends
it's just pure business so i guess my
question would be uh
you said that you were going to press
china you signed on to the
g7 communique that said you the g7 were
calling on china to open up
to let the investigators in but china
basically says they don't want to be
interfered with anymore so what happens
now
the impact the world's attitude toward
china as it develops china's trying very
hard
to project itself as a responsible
and very very forthcoming nation
that they are trying very hard to talk
about how they're taking and
helping the world in terms of cover 19
and vaccines and
they're trying very hard look certain
things
you don't have to explain to the people
of the world
they see the results is china really
actually trying to get to the bottom of
this one thing we did discuss
right as i told you in the eu and at the
g7 and with nato what we should be doing
and what i'm going to
make an effort to do is rally the
world to work on what is going to be the
physical mechanism available to detect
early on the next pandemic
and have a mechanism by which we can
respond to it and respond to it early
it's going to happen it's going to
happen and we need to do that thank you
president biden addressing key issues
ranging from
cyber security so there it is a very
very
interesting press conference i have to
tell you i found that quite interesting
do so i've been getting a ton of people
asking me to talk about like the tyt
etc drama i do have a clip i recorded
today
if i'm able to pull it up i don't know
if it's done processing do people want
us do you want a preview of it
is that something people i mean i don't
know if the live stream audience wants
it but i've gotten dozens of emails and
tweets saying
talk about what's going on with the left
oh hold on looks like biden's back
into the world i'm not confident of
anything i'm just stating the fact
but given his past behavior has not
changed and in that press conference
after sitting down with you
for several hours he denied any
involvement in cyber attacks
he downplayed human rights abuses he
even refused to say alexei navoni's name
so how does that account to a
constructive meeting as president
president putin you don't understand
that you're in your own business
it's a seventh oh whoa
[Music]
getting wow so it seems like it is
finally over
okay let me see if i can pull this up
and we'll preview oh okay hold on
i see if i sign in we'll be able to see
this
because the video is private right now
let me see if i can pull this up for you
guys
uh oh boy
okay yeah so this is just a preview this
will be publishing later okay
i'm gonna run it just for now at 1.5 x
speed
this is just a preview of like my my
thoughts on the left wing drama okay
okay i have received dozens of emails
and tweets and comments asking me to
weigh in about what's currently
happening with the online left as many
of you know i really don't watch much
online political media i limit myself to
the stuff i read to be ready to do the
show and then i have other interests and
limited time each day but
i am sort of aware of a bunch of the
different things that have been going on
with the online left and i want to talk
about it a little bit because i do think
that it's actually
there's a lot to say here now as i
understand it there's a few different
controversies happening right now
i am very much aware of young turks host
jan yuger and also young turk's host
anna casparian embroiled in again if i
understand it correctly it's a couple of
different controversies
one is specifically related to another
host named jimmy dore and sexual
harassment right i'm on coffee in this
clip smith doesn't like to say
and then another kind of more general
controversy is between jenk and the
young turks and a sort of contingent of
the authoritarian revolutionary left
that has a presence online people like
glenn greenwald and others i'm not
exactly sure who else is part of this
and so a few things are going on
uh there and then on the other hand it
seems as though there was kind of a
shakeup at the hills rising and there
are new hosts there
and that seems to be going pretty poorly
from the one one thing i read about it
and the question i've basically been
getting from people in the audience
is whether the online left is tearing
itself apart in a way that is counter
productive to the progressive movement
and whether the left has become overrun
with with grifters so let's take these
questions one at a time and i want to
say i was actually just interviewed for
a podcast
uh by cliff schechter and john aravosis
where we talk quite a bit about this and
we're gonna publish this over the
weekend and um we talk a lot about this
issue
if the topic interests you there's you
know probably 20 minutes of this stuff
in that episode which we'll publish to
our youtube channel so first of all
the fact that there are different views
on the quote left is not bad it's not a
source for concern and it's always been
my perspective that diversity of opinion
is fine and good and should be applauded
and
welcomed right has been a concern for me
has been the increased gatekeeping that
i've seen some on the left engage in
which includes call outs about who
really is or isn't on the left i've
received many of those
as well as kind of shaming people's
reviews and generally unproductive
insults when somebody doesn't line up
100 with your political perspective
generally speaking diversity of opinion
is good it's not a problem in and of
itself what is a problem
is when people start to focus merely on
calling out others either for personal
reasons or for clicks or for money or to
gatekeep or to virtue signal or for
whatever reason they do it so i'm going
to give you an example
when jimmy dore has attacked me he did
on twitter during the election period
last year
i've mentioned my views differ from
jimmy dores but i don't base my show and
my identity around calling out
people like jimmy dore with whom i have
differences of opinion first of all it
just seems so boring
secondly it's so childish third what
would i even get from doing that it
would probably be profitable and i've
jokingly talked with others about who
should i start a fake beef with
because it gets attention but it's just
not me it's not productive in any real
sense
now the issue of grifters is a
complicated one and when i say grifter
what i mean is someone is creating a
persona and covering stories
or taking positions or covering stories
in a way that doesn't represent who they
really are either because they've
decided i can concoct this persona and
appeal to a certain audience or it's
going to be profitable in some way i
might get paid speaking gigs or whatever
the case may be now here's what i can
say about that
i'm going to give you a list of people
that i know are not grifters and what i
mean by that is whether we agree or
disagree on any particular issue
what you see them say publicly lines up
completely with what they say privately
they are not playing characters
they're not calculating their positions
for how it's going to be perceived by
their audiences or for profitability and
the reason i'm able to give you this
list is because i know both these
people's
uh public work as well as knowing them
privately as individuals
and in no particular order here are
people that are not grifters um
jenga anna from the young turks i've
known them both for a long time if you
talk to them privately
what they say is exactly what they say
on their show we don't have to agree
about everything
surely i'd have differences with them
about for example the
israeli-palestinian conflict but
they are totally sincere in what they
say and what they believe would be best
for the world i am totally sincere in
what i say
there is no grift or calculation there
great okay sam cedar from the majority
report i've been to what must be at this
point 15 or 20 conferences with sam over
the years where we spend hours together
every political conversation i've had
with sam and that i've heard and
overheard
sam have with other folks including
people from the revolutionary left etc
the public sam and the private sam is
exactly the same person no gift
kyle kalinski i've hung out with kyle um
and i've talked to kyle a ton
over the years the kyle you see on his
youtube channel as far as i know and
again i don't watch a lot of this stuff
online
it's the same kyle that i know privately
farron cousins from ring of fire
is the same guy politically privately as
he is publicly um no mickey from the no
mickey show
i've known her for probably a decade
private nomaki and public nomaki are the
same person
uh this is not someone who i guess we
traditionally consider to be on the left
and this i don't know how my audience
will react to this
joe rogan whatever your problems are
with the things rogan says and i
recently did a video where i said i
disagree with what joe is saying about
vaccination i think he's mistaken
uh there is no act there i can tell you
rogan five minutes before the show
starts and an hour after and on the show
it's the real rogan okay now anybody
outside of this list some of them are
grifters but many of them i just don't
know privately so i can't really say i
don't know well enough to say
their public persona is different than
the person they are in private either
for profit or not some i don't want to
name names because then i'm just
engaging in the same stuff but there are
plenty of grifters
so then the question is is the griffin
going to tear the left apart but
probably not
um some people will make money and are
making money um
with the grifting with the calculated
fake personas there are others who will
then make money from attacking the
grifters
and on and on it's not really my thing i
don't think it's particularly good for
the progressive movement to have
people with retrograde ideologies
passing themselves as being on the left
you know if you
are an authoritarian or a faux populist
or you defend or sympathize the
authoritarians or the faux populists and
the dictators and the strongmen
i would question whether you're really
on the left it's not a left i recognize
but i don't know that it's really going
to tear the left apart a lot of these
movements
seem way bigger if you look at twitter
and reddit and youtube than they really
are but it's going to continue being
profitable so it's going to continue
that's basically my take and a lot of it
is very boring a lot of it is
extraordinarily childish and the
unfortunate reality is that to some
degree
we're all slightly narcissistic and what
i mean by that is anybody who i mean
okay if
you're neurodivergent then there this
may not apply okay but for people who
are
you know not autistic and you decide i'm
going to have a show where i give my
opinion
there's some degree of narcissism there
there has to be because somewhere you
believe that
your opinion uh maybe as opposed to or
different than
millions and millions and millions of
people who it never occurs to do a show
your opinion is of some value
entertainment or it's something that
other people would want to listen to so
you're going to have a lot of
interesting and different personalities
in this space
but within that there's a huge huge
spectrum and by its nature
you're going to get this this stuff
within the space and i think that
there are aspects of it that aren't good
for the progressive movement but i don't
think it's ultimately going to be
destructive in
in the way that some believe it's going
to be because much of the survival of
this very space the online left
depends on conflict and depends on
controversy and so the the idea that it
will become a distraction from policy
sure
but it's not going to destroy the space
overall all right so that's basically my
take on all of this left tube stuff
that's going on and
you know i'm not even i'm not even uh uh
paying it i'm not even
engaging but there's already over even
over the last few hours
now some of the revolutionary left let
me do it at that speed
now even over the last hour and a half
some of the revolutionary left is
turning their attention to me and i'm
not even going to respond i've actually
muted a lot of them on twitter and i
have no really interested in engaging on
that
um because it's just a waste of time
okay guys so
that's going to do it for today thank
you to everybody who joined and signed
up
and sent super chats and all of this
different stuff
okay so i will see everybody later
and we have a new show coming up
tomorrow
you